ségolène royal a feuilleté maintenant
votre votre album un album photo mêlant
vie privée et vie publique a craqué
clarence road again
cette visite et c'est vrai que c'est pas
facile parce que c'est en même temps vie
privée donc auquel on a droit mais en
même temps c'est vrai que c'est assez
exceptionnel et je fais aussi pour pour
la cause des femmes fait d'avoir été à
l'elysée me donne une force
exceptionnelle
je connais les rouages de l'état
l'administration ne m'impressionne pas
c'est à dire que c'est avec l'expérience
de ma circonscription que je n'aurais
mes interventions l'assemblée nationale
et je crois que sans cet appui sur le
terrain un élu n'est rien
ça passe il ya beaucoup de députés qui
oserait s'impliquer sur un fromage dont
moi j'ai choisi de le faire parce que je
pense que précisément c'est une
production de très haute qualité et qu'à
partir du moment où un député veut
défendre son terroir il doit pas hésiter
et il doit s'impliquer justement sur les
productions qui font l'identité de ce
terroir comme en diamants
oui on a des vacances ordinaire parce
que on donne la priorité aux d'enfants à
la famille
au juin tout ça est pris dans ces
conditions là
on n'a pas le sentiment d'avoir des
vacances extraordinaire 100 foot qu'on a
le sentiment d'avoir une vie
extraordinaire est donné